good morning John first I cannot believe
it's been five years since tiffy OS life
keeps passing us by second I'm sorry to
hear about you Reba have no idea what
that must feel like and I hope I never
find out and third today I want to talk
about happiness because we humans are
not particularly good at knowing what
makes us happy so sometimes we have to
be told and of the happiness increasing
strategies that I hear about they almost
all seem to be either obvious not well
supported by science difficult to
implement or to only produce short-term
gains and happiness not long-term
there's one thing that I found that hits
the golden trifecta here it has
measurable significant dose-dependent
peer-reviewed impact it's both
actionable and passive meaning that it's
something that a lot of people can do
and once you do it it's hard to undo and
it's not intuitive meaning it actually
helps to be told because it's not
obvious your commute to work is a
magnificent source of unhappiness
unpleasantness stress and even
unhealthiness this commute is rated by
most workers as the least pleasant thing
that they do every day we are making
dear Hank and John with those people in
mind
hopefully it's helping the happiest
commuters commute by bicycle the least
happy commute alone in a vehicle by
themselves which is of course by far the
most common way that we commute commute
over one hour are linked not just to
stress but to chronic pain and a high
cholesterol even with long commutes are
also less likely to have time for
physical leisure and on average spend
less time with friends we often do not
consider the magnitude of impact that
our commute will have on our lives when
we're making big decisions like where we
will work and where we will live moving
closer to work even if it means living
in a smaller or more expensive or both
place it's often the far better decision
for personal happiness even though the
effects of the larger house or the more
money or the better job seemed far more
present in our minds the blankness of
the commute this lost time it's not easy
for our minds to consider according to
one study freeing up an hour-long
commute was the same happiness gain as
going from a $60,000 a year job to
$100,000 a year job people with the
longest commutes in one study were found
to have the least amount of satisfaction
with their lives owning a home or moving
to a bigger place has been found to have
no long-term impact on
average happiness of course the ability
to choose a longer commute is a luxury
in itself a luxury that is not available
to everyone is why it's also important
that we allow our cities to grow in more
dense ways and that those who live in
established neighborhoods that are close
to where people work don't fight to
prohibit dense development which in the
course of trying to protect the
character of our neighborhoods we often
do if there's no new inventory nearby
the jobs there will always have to be
more commuting into the jobs this is bad
for the environment but it's also bad
for the people who have to drive 90
minutes each way to work research
continually indicates that happiness is
not about what we have but about what we
do with the individual minutes and hours
and days of our lives and that can be
surprisingly hugely affected by the
decisions that we make in urban planning
and how we build our city and also the
individual decisions that individual
people make often using faulty
decision-making processes that our
brains aren't really designed for so
just remember that on average spending
upwards of 10% of your waking hours
alone in a car even if you do have the
company of dear Hank and John should be
avoided if it can be John I'll see you
on Tuesday we're doing a thing at dftba
called the awesome Sox Cup I'm just a
huge fan of weird Sox I can do this with
my leg because I'm flexible yeah and
again I'm both up there I can't so these
are the socks these are the first ones
the dftba awesome Sox Club will deliver
a new pair of socks to you every single
month you won't know what they're gonna
look like until they arrive though but
they're gonna be weird